Good morning church.
Good morning, church. There you go.
Uh, my name's TR Lewis, uh, one of the elders here.
It's a pleasure to be with you.
Um, I'm not sure if you've ever tried to carry a table
with a plum bob on it.
Um, but it's not easy. And
so I got better from first service to this service.
I grew a little bit, um,
but it's a treat to get to be here with you guys
and open God's word.
Um, this morning, this morning,
we're gonna pick back up in Romans chapter 12, verse 11.
We've been studying through this section
of Romans over the last few weeks.
And you know that this is a, the center section
of Paul's longest letter that he wrote in the New Testament.
Um, it's a letter where he begins with 11 chapters
of telling us about the why of following Christ,
about the theology of following Christ.
And then he moves into chapter 12 with the how.
And so we've been looking at that over these last few weeks.
We've been using it, um, as we realign our lives
and following after Christ.
And, and we've used this example of this PBO
that hangs and points us to Christ.
It sinners us and certainly if we believe that
as we've repented of our sins
and turn from our old way of life,
that this new life in Christ should look very
different as we move forward.
So in Romans chapter 12, Paul begins to unpack for us
with instruction what that life looks like.
Jesus lived it out perfectly,
but then Paul gives us words that we're to, to live by.
And so as we use this plum Bob,
many times our flesh bumps up against it
and tries to push it to the right or to the left.
We sway back and forth.
And one of my friends, one of my good friends,
uses the phrase, the cautionary phrase,
there's a ditch on both sides of the road
that if you veer too far to the left
or too far to the right, you might find yourself in a ditch.
And I didn't. I understood that,
but I hadn't experienced it till recently.
And about six weeks ago, um, I got that experience.
Um, I found myself in a ditch.
I was on my way back from Stillwater.
Um, I had just gotten my car outta the shop.
I have an old car for UU students. It was from the 1990s.
It's a nineties Toyota, so it's old,
but I, I just got outta the shop Now.
This car has been reborn a few times.
And and this was a tuneup. This was a realignment.
I was getting some things fixed
and it was fresh from the Toyota dealership.
And so I'm driving back from Stillwater.
And actually that day I was, uh, supposed to be preparing
for a sermon, but I decided
before I would go to the coffee shop or library
or home to work, I might take a detour.
So I took a detour from what I was supposed to be doing.
I turned off on Indian Meridian off of Highway 51.
Now, if you know anything about Indian Meridian,
it's not all paved.
And so as I came through coil,
I was heading south with zeal.
I was probably listening to a sermon or podcast or,
or, or something really good.
I was thinking about though my detour,
I was thinking about I was gonna go by and check some ponds
and see how much water was in 'em because it was raining.
And in that moment when the asphalt gave way
and it turned to red clay, I got sideways.
I didn't make it 50 yards.
And then I was 90 degrees in the ditch, as you saw.
So I was standing there in the ditch.
Well, I was standing in my car.
I had to stand on my passenger side door, um,
because it was on its side and I couldn't get out.
I was stuck. And I realized in that moment
what it meant to be stuck in a ditch.
So I texted that picture to my friend, so now I get it,
but I couldn't rescue myself.
I couldn't get, I had to call for help.
So the coil volunteer firefighters came.
The Oklahoma Highway Patrol came
and ultimately Darrel's wrecker service came.
Darrel's wrecker service came and he looked at that
and he said, that's bad, but I'll tell you,
he flipped me straight and he pulled me out of the ditch
and put me back up on the road.
And Darryl helped me check the oil
and there was oil in the engine.
So that started up. So we started it up and I drove it home,
and I'm still driving it today.
I drove to church. It's in the parking
lot if you wanna take a look.
But as I was driving home, I noticed something
that it was pulling a little bit to the right.
So you see that that alignment work
that I just had done was knocked back out of alignment.
So the only repair that I needed to do
after flipping 90 degrees into a ditch with the help
of Darrell, I was righted, checked to make sure I was safe,
but I had to get my alignment redone in my car.
And my prayer this morning is that Romans chapter 12,
verse 11 will serve in some ways as a realignment for us,
because there's three phrases.
And those three phrases, the first two, we can veer off
to one way or the other.
But the third one will write us in the
center and keep us straight.
So as we come to verse 11 today, we'll read it.
It says, do not be thoughtful and zeal.
Be fervent in the Spirit, serve the Lord.
And years ago, the Lewis family adopted this section
of Romans, Romans nine
or 12, nine through 13 as a verse for our family.
And so I'm not much of an artist, um,
but I tried to encapsulate this in an acrostic poem.
If you know what that is, you take the letters of a word
and then you put words out next to it.
So I jotted out these words for our family.
It says, love, encourage, and witness and service.
Now I know that five words can
encapsulate all of these verses.
And over the last few weeks we've been studying that we are
to love one another.
We're to love with brotherly affection.
We're to outdo one another in showing zeal.
We're to love and to hold fast to what is good,
and we are too abhor and run away from what is evil.
And today, Paul goes on
and he calls us to three things, to be thoughtful,
to not be thoughtful in zeal,
to be fervent in the spirit and to serve the Lord.
So let's start with the first one, zeal.
So zeal is passionate enthusiasm.
That passionate enthusiasm often
spills over into one's actions.
Zeal is a drive for your life.
It affects everything that you do.
But it's still, it's still kind of just a concept.
And these are all kind of concepts today.
And as I move through, I wanna paint a picture for us today.
So in your notes, you have room to jot and write.
You can draw a picture if you want to.
But I'm gonna paint a picture with people of
what these three things look like.
The first is zeal. Now, last time I preached up here,
I talked about, we were studying Psalm 66, a shout
to the Lord, and we talked about the Aggie.
Whoop, nobody remembers it clearly.
Um, but the first service nine,
nine o'clock did, I'm just saying.
But um, so we talked about the Aggie whoop.
Well, on that campus there are five guys called the fight in
Texas, Aggie, Yale leaders that are a picture of zeal.
Now time doesn't permit
nor to be glorifying to God
to talk too much about the Yale leaders,
but they are a picture of zeal.
They wear funny clothes, but they do it with a purpose.
These guys run around campus and they yell
and they jump, they tell stories with gusto.
They lead the crowd in cheering on the team,
and they stir in others of love for Texas a and m.
These guys, they, they're there for a purpose
and that zeal drives them.
But Paul doesn't call us just
to like run around and do stuff.
He calls us to do it with a purpose.
Now, there's some people, the ditch on the side of
that is sloth or slothfulness.
And so Paul guards us against that.
He says, don't just be slothful.
Now, that's not a word that we throw
around a lot in Edmond in 2025,
but the word in Spanish for sloth the animal, right?
Maybe some of you have seen a sloth in the wild.
The same word is used for sloth perso as it is for
being lazy perso.
Now, if you've seen a sloth in the wild, they're very slow.
And maybe more of you have seen the movie Zootopia
and the sloth in Zootopia that works at the DMV,
who speaks very slowly
and moves very slowly.
It's painful. It's painful for me to watch that scene
because that that sloth is not getting anything done.
And I think that's what Paul is guarding against us,
guarding us against.
You see, he wants us to serve with an energy
and an enthusiasm and an efficacy following after Christ.
And a picture of that in our church
that I think about are guys like Scotty Louderback
and Jeff Berkholder.
Guys like Bill Netherland
and David Matheson who's serving hillside kids.
There's so many more today wearing their t-shirts
that are gonna be serving with zeal this week.
And so zeal, these guys, paint a picture for me of zeal.
They often wear funny clothes, but with a purpose.
They often jump and sing and, and act out stories,
but it's for the purpose of pointing kids
and even adults to the Lord.
And these men are all deacons in our church.
They get stuff done, they serve behind the scenes.
And deacon benevolence, they care for widows.
They do so many things around our church.
In zeal, God's word also gives us
an example of zeal.
We see that in the Apostle Peter,
and we know that we, that Peter's zeal wasn't always
perfectly lived out,
but we see zeal in Peter in the way that he left everything.
He left everything to follow Christ.
He was in that boat fishing
and he walked away from that to follow a zeal after Christ.
We see the zeal of Peter as he challenged Christ
and he was rebuked.
We see the zeal of Peter as he drew his sword
to cut off the ear of the guard that came to arrest Jesus.
But we see that zeal of Peter refined
and redeemed as Jesus restores Peter by
that seashore as he's cooking the fish
over the charcoal fire.
And he says, Peter, will you feed my sheep?
And that zeal of Peters refined
and reshaped in service to the Lord, he was called the rock
that Christ would use to build his church in the world.
And later in Peter's first epistle,
we have some words about Zeal Peter's own words
that he wrote to those early dispersed Christians,
but are good for us today.
So let's look in first Peter chapter three,
verses eight through 13.
He says, finally, all of you have unity of mind,
sympathy, brotherly love,
and a tender heart and a humble mind.
Do not repay evil for evil or reviling for reviling.
But on the contrary, bless for to this you were called
that you may obtain a blessing for whoever desires
to love life and see good days.
Let him keep his tongue from evil and his lips from deceit.
Let him turn away from evil and do good.
Let him seek peace and pursue it.
For the eyes of the Lord are on the righteous
and his ears are open to their prayer.
But the face of the Lord is against those who do evil.
Now, who is there to harm you if you are zealous
for doing what is good.
You see, Peter writes to these, these early believers
and reminds them these words
that middle sections actually from Psalm chapter 34,
where David is glorifying God.
He's reminding himself
and he's also reminding the singers
that it's God who lifts us up.
It's God who pulls us out of the ditch.
It's God who puts us back on the path with zeal.
Now, some of you may feel like you're already in that ditch,
some may feel like you're sliding towards it
and some may feel like you've been put back up,
but you're still needing to be realigned.
But let us remember these words that if we're zealous
for doing good, if that's our purpose, if we're following
after Christ, the way Peter calls us, that there's no one,
no one who's against us or who can be against us.
But most perfectly we see the zeal
of the Lord played out in our Lord and Savior Jesus Christ.
In fact, we read in the prophecy of Jesus
and Isaiah chapter nine about the zeal of the Lord
and Isaiah nine, six,
and seven, he writes, for to us, a child is born unto us.
A son is given and the government shall
be upon his shoulders.
His name shall be called wonderful Counselor
Almighty God, the everlasting Father
and prince of peace, of the increase
of his government and of peace.
There will be no end on the throne of David
and over his kingdom to establish it
and to uphold it with righteousness
and justice from this time forth and forevermore.
Now, this is a lofty prophecy.
It's a lofty thing that God is laying out
through his prophet Isaiah to the people.
And then he says this, he says, the zeal of the Lord
of hosts will do this.
You see Jesus coming to this earth, coming
as the fulfillment of that prophecy's testimony of the zeal
of the Lord of hosts.
It's a visible sign.
And then we see that zeal of the Lord played out in the life
of Christ as he lived and walked with a passion
and conviction, not shrinking away from the oppression
or persecution that he faced,
but rather being that wonderful counselor
living in the flesh as mighty God
and establishing forever as a prince of peace.
You see, Jesus lived with a passion for God
and he lived with a passion for others.
He was excited about it.
We don't read about him running around or or jumping or
or all these exuberant things.
But he lived his life filled
and driven by a passion, a zeal for God's glory, a zeal
for the redemption of the lost, for the restoration
of the broken for salvation
and healing of the sick and the hurting.
The zeal of the Lord was in him.
The passion and energy was lived out,
and it was never ineffectively slow
and it was never hurried in any way.
Jesus' pace of life
and pace of ministry was fueled
by the spirit in perfect zeal.
And in fact, today the the zeal for the things
of the world can try to draw us away.
It can push us to the left or to the right.
But if you look to Christ's example of being fueled
with the zeal of the Lord, it writes us.
And so Paul gives us another phrase,
another instruction or a command.
He tells us to be fervent in spirit.
And you, you see each of these phrases
kind of builds one on the other.
So we're called to not be thoughtful in zeal,
but the next, he calls us to be fervent in spirit.
And this word fervent is again, one
that we don't use every day in Edmond,
uh, in today's language.
But it, it has its roots in the word for boiling
or the idea of boiling that as you apply energy
or heat to a pot of water, it starts to stir
and move and bubble.
And eventually that turns into a boil.
And as you as that flame stays, that boil turns into a roll.
And then is in that place that that pot of water
that was sitting lukewarm, it becomes effective for work.
It produces heat, it can cook pasta,
it can make tea, it can make coffee.
That pot of water can do so many things as
that heat is applied to it.
There's an additional kind of facet of the word fervor
or fervent that I think about kind of a groundedness
or a connectedness when I think of fervor.
And I think that has to do with, with a proximity to
that source of energy
or keeping that pot close to the flame, close to the heat.
When I was at Texas a
and m, I had a fervor
for the Aggie spirit 'cause I was on campus.
I was close to the action, I went to all the football games.
But as I've moved far away, that fervor has died down.
Many people would say that's a good thing
and we got some amens in the first service.
But Paul calls us to be fervent in spirit
and some versions even say fervent in the spirit,
that we allow the Holy Spirit to be the one that fuels us
and energizes us.
Now there are many in our church that display fervency
of spirit, but I think none more so than Ryan Whitaker.
You see, Ryan is a, is an elder brother.
And through this process, I've gotten
to know him more and more.
And the closer I've gotten with him,
the more time I've spent, the more I see his
fervency of spirit.
Ryan stays in proximity to the flame through prayer
and through bible study, through scripture memorization
and through meditation, he allows the Holy Spirit
to fuel his spirit
and this rolling boil of spirit that Ryan has
that spills out to others.
He uses that energy, that boiling
to bless through mentoring.
He mentors men, young and old.
He leads a community group of young couples with his wife.
He serves in so many ways, he comforts with the comfort
that he has been given in Christ.
And he's fueled by the spirit in all these ways.
If you don't know Ryan, get to meet him.
Listen closely to him
and get a sense of what it looks like
to be maintained in the spirit at a rolling boil.
In scripture, Paul uses the phrase,
the same phrase, fervent in spirit to describe
his partner in ministry and fellow preacher Apollos.
In Acts chapter 18, he introduces us to Apollos.
He, he introduces him this way.
He says, now a Jew named Apollos, a native of Alexandria,
came to Ephesus.
He was eloquent in spirit. I'm sorry.
He was an eloquent man, competent in the scriptures
and had it been instructed in the way of the Lord
and being fervent in spirit, he spoke
and taught accurately the things concerning Jesus.
Though he knew only the baptism of John, he began
to speak boldly in the synagogues.
But when Priscilla and Aquila heard him, they took him aside
and explained to him the way of the God more accurately.
And when he wished to cross to Acha,
the brothers encouraged him
and wrote to the disciples to welcome him.
And when he arrived, he greatly helped those who
through grace and believed
for he powerfully refuted the Jews in public, showing
by the scriptures that the Christ was Jesus.
So we see Apollo described by Paul being fervent in spirit,
the very phrase that he uses
to refine us in Romans chapter 12.
So we, we should look at what
that looked like in the life of Apollo.
We see that Apollo's spirit was boiling, he was fueled,
he was heated up by knowledge of God,
a competency in the scriptures and a willingness to learn.
He was fervent in spirit.
And that fervent ness of spirit, that fervor spilled out.
It spilled out on those around him and his teaching.
He was teaching in the synagogue of all places.
And Paul tells us that he had an eloquence of speech
and he accurately taught the things of God.
And yet Apollo still needed instruction
and still needed refining.
And one Corinthians, we see that fervor of Apollos,
that powerful teaching had the effect
of followers in the congregation professing a following
or allegiance to Apollos over
and above the other teachers, over and above Paul, and, and
and an allegiance to Apollos.
Because you see that fervor, that fervency
of spirit is powerful and it can be misdirected
or misused for self-service.
And so we're to guard against that.
We read later in one Corinthians
that Paul does correct those believers.
He tells them that, that it's not Paul, it's not Apollos,
it's not any other teacher.
It's God who gives the growth.
It's the spirit that brings about that, that life
in the body of Christ.
And so we see that, that that fervor working in
and through Apollos can be used to glorify God,
that can also be misapplied and distracted.
But we see the fervor
of spirit never more present than in the life of our savior.
This is how Jesus reveals to us the fervency of Spirit.
He came on this earth in the flesh,
and yet he was also fully God through his life.
He maintained perfect communion
with the Father and the Spirit.
He was fueled by the spirit.
We see him led by the Spirit as he goes into the wilderness
and he rebuked the twisted attacks of Satan
through the truth of scripture.
We see Christ's fervent spirit in that he was fully aware
of the needs and compassionate towards those around him.
He was sensitive in the spirit to the things
that he encountered that would rob God of his glory
or distort the image of the Father.
You see, Jesus did boil.
He had that rolling boil inside
and he bubbled over in that fervor in perfect ways.
He never drifted too far Away from the flame.
He was always imp perfect communion when the Spirit,
and he didn't give in to the temptation
of self glorification in the wilderness.
He did it perfectly. He walked perfectly in the spirit.
And so we see this morning
that we might be thoughtful in zeal,
or we might be just doing things for zeal sake.
We might drift far from the flame
and we cool down to being lukewarm or we might boil over
and self-glorification and self service.
But this last phrase ties it all together.
Paul writes to us to serve the Lord.
It's in serving the Lord that those things come together.
It unites our spirit.
It gives us a plum
because as we serve the Lord, we have one focus.
We have one purpose. And Paul uses this closing
phrase in this verse to narrow in and focus our zeal
and focus our fervency.
And I use, I love the fact that he uses the word serve
because Paul referred to himself as a servant.
He saw himself that way.
First and foremost, he identified in the epistles
as an apostle or of Christ.
But then the second most frequent title that he uses is that
of servant or even bond servant a doo.
And it wasn't just the way he identified.
He lived it out in what he did everywhere that he went.
And again, in our church, we have so many
that serve so well.
It's because of service that you see all
of these decorations around us.
People could have spent their weekend anyway they wanted to,
but they chose to come and help serve the Lord.
But to put a face, to put a person
for service in Henderson Hills, I think about Jill Wagman.
Jill's a faithful member of Henderson Hills
and also a servant in our congregation
and a member of our staff.
She uses every hour of her workday and many hours
after her workday in serving the church,
She serves the Lord in what she does,
but it's also who she is.
She's a servant and her staff position, she leads
and oversees the teams that plan events that care
for our property, that organize the cafe
and provide for so much that goes on
around here at Henderson Hills.
But it's not just in the leading that she serves.
She jumps in on the cooking and the cleaning, the setting up
and the tearing down from coordination
and planning to the end of the execution.
She's there. And I'm certain
that Jill could apply these skills
anywhere that she chooses.
And in a dozen of different settings.
Yet she chooses to serve the Lord here
at Henderson Hills this summer.
We have other examples. We have students,
high school students who have chosen
to serve in the summer leadership program here
through our student ministry, that they could have gotten a
job at any of a number of different places.
And yet they've given themselves to serving the Lord.
And this week, this week, this building's gonna be filled
with people in colorful T-shirts serving the Lord
and sharing the love of Jesus Christ with boys
and girls from our church and from our community.
You see, one can be zealous for the wrong things.
One can be lazy and zeal.
You can get in the ditch on those sides.
One can be fueled by the things of the world
and not fueled by the spirit.
But as we serve the Lord, it sinners us.
It gives a purpose to those things that we do.
And we see Paul as a servant of the Lord.
But I thought it might be interesting to also
to have an Old Testament example of
what it looks like to serve the Lord.
And so you remember Moses, Moses born
during a rough season, put in the river by his mother
for protection and then taken in, fostered
and ultimately adopted by the wife of Pharaoh.
Moses grew up and affluence.
He grew up in the um,
with the Pharaoh in the palace.
He grew up to be, uh, prominent in Egypt.
He had every opportunity to serve himself
and every reason to, and yet God, God called him
to serve the Lord through the burning bush.
He called Moses out of that to something different,
to serve the Lord with fervor and with zeal.
Now we see Moses not do that perfectly all the time,
but the Lord used him to lead the nation of Israel
and to show them what it looked like to serve the Lord
and to serve the Lord with a singularity of devotion.
And Deuteronomy chapter 11, he writes it this way.
And if you will indeed obey my commandments,
that I command you today to love the Lord
and to serve him with all of your heart
and with all of your so soul, he'll give the rain
for your land in its season, the early rain
and the later rain that you may gather in your grain
and your wine and your oil.
You see, Moses knew that there was a singularity of service
that happened before the Lord, that we could,
we could not be distracted by the world around us
or the the enemies that attack.
And he passed that devotion, that singularity
of devotion down to Joshua.
You remember that as a nation
of Israel entered into the promised land.
They weren't free from distractions,
they weren't free from persecutions,
they weren't free from hard times.
And what they faced is not unlike what we faced today.
And as we get to the end of that book,
there's this famous line from Joshua.
He says, as for me in my house, we will serve the Lord.
Now, Joshua probably didn't have
that printed on his coffee cup.
It wasn't a a cross ditch on his desk.
It was a call and it was a challenge that he laid out.
I'm gonna read this whole section for you.
So this is Joshua chapter 24, verses 14 through 17.
It says, this is Joshua speaking to the people.
He says, now therefore, fear the Lord
and serve him in sincerity and in faithfulness.
Put away the gods that your father serve beyond the river
and in Egypt and serve the Lord.
And if it is evil in your eyes to serve the Lord,
choose this day whom you'll serve,
whether the gods your Father served in the region
beyond the river or the gods of the Amorites
and whose land you dwell.
But as for me and my house, we will serve the Lord.
Then the people answered far be it from us,
that we should forsake the Lord and serve other gods.
For it is for the, it is the Lord, our God who brought us
and our fathers up out of the land of Egypt, out
of the house of slavery, and
who did great signs in our sight
and preserved us in all the way that we went.
And among all the peoples through whom we passed.
And the Lord drove us, drove out before us, all the peoples
and the Amorites who lived in the land.
Therefore, we will serve the Lord for he is our God.
You see, they recognized that it was the Lord
who had pulled them up out of the ditch.
They realized that it was the Lord
who had put them back on the path
and who had actually cleared the path before them
and was making their way straight.
They had attacks from every side.
They had distractions from every side.
And yet they chose to serve the Lord.
And if you know very much about the rest
of the Old Testament, they continue to need realignment
and refining from time to time.
But again, in serving the Lord, we have Jesus
as our ultimate, our pinnacle example.
He lived out perfectly what it looks like to live
with singularity of focus in serving the Lord.
And in one verse, he says it in John chapter five,
verse 30, he tells his disciples, I can do nothing on my own
as I hear, I judge.
And my judgment is just because I seek not my own will,
but the will of him who sent me.
You see, Jesus served the Lord during his life
and ministry on this earth and in the flesh.
But he served as a perfect imprint of the invisible God.
He, he served the Lord with a singularity of focus.
His whole goal was to point to the Father.
But how does that keep us upright?
How does that keep us between the ditches?
How does serving the Lord do that?
Well, it causes everything else to fade away.
It causes us to remember who we indeed are serving.
And Paul, Paul tells us in Ephesians
chapter six, he writes it this way.
He says, bonds servants obey your earthly masters with fear
and trembling with a sincere heart as you would Christ.
Not by way of I service as people pleasers,
but as bond servants of Christ, doing the will
of God from the heart, rendering service with a goodwill as
to the Lord and not to man.
So the beauty of being zealous, the beauty
of being fervent in spirit
and the beauty of serving the Lord is that it is perfectly
what God has called us to do is the way
that he wants us to go.
The rub is everything in our flesh pushes back against that.
Our flesh wants to be lazy.
Our flesh wants to be lukewarm.
Our flesh wants to serve our flesh.
But we're reminded in one John
and he says in one John chapter four, little children,
you are from God and you have overcome them.
For he who is in you is greater than he
that is in the world.
And so we're reminded that we're not called
to do this on our own.
We remember that Peter and his zeal fell apart,
but very kindly and very graciously.
He was restored. He was restored to serve the Lord.
And we see that fervency of Apollos begin
to cause him to drift
to the temptation of being self-serving.
But we see him restored and refined
and used to serve the Lord.
You see, serving the Lord puts us in the middle of the road.
And this morning, whether you feel like you need
to be pulled out of the ditch
or whether you need to be aligned, know that it's in Christ
that we find that salvation.
It's in the Holy Spirit, that we find that source
for our fervency,
and it's for his purpose, for the glory of His name,
that he works all of those things out in our lives.
So this morning, let us go to the Lord in prayer.
Let us pray that as we serve, we would do it with the zeal
that He's called us to and the fervency of the Spirit.
Father God, your word is very clear to us that our life
and you should look different than the world around us.
And when we're laying in the ditch,
when the world is 90 degrees to us, that you pull us out,
you put us back on the path.
And Father, as we're on that path,
you don't just leave us there.
You give us a zeal. You give us your spirit to fuel us,
to give us a rolling boil, an energy
to serve others in your name and for your glory.
Father, we pray that as we serve as a church,
that it would be for your glory.
And Lord, this morning, thank you for the brothers
and sisters that are here.
Thank you for those who have come to hear of your good news
and your name maybe for the first time.
And I pray, father, that your spirit would work
to fan into flame, that which you've put into us.
That's in Christ name we pray, amen.
And my brother, Ryan Whitaker, is gonna come
and lead us in the Lord's Supper together.